le modèle de transport maritime
martiniquais va-t-il séduire les
décideurs guadeloupéens pour le savoir
rien de tel pour le président du conseil
régional de poitou pitre qu'une
traversée de la baie de fort-de-france
sur l'une des vedettes martiniquaise à
bord les échanges entre la collectivité
territoriale de martinique et ses hôtes
sont soutenus le capitaine offre même
son siège au poste de commandement on
voit que les gens sont à l'aise
et puis ceux qui sont sanctionnés schéma
deux sont des experts en la matière
bompard par conséquent nous essaierons
de prendre tous au pied bien si pour
transporter là bas la guadeloupe a pour
ambition la création de deux lignes port
louis petit canal et vieux bourg pointe
à pitre contrairement à la martinique
une seule institution a autorité en la
matière le transport en guadeloupe va
regrouper plusieurs opérateurs doivent
ou pendus communauté d'agglomération
sans voir un cap excellence
il ya du levant et l'organisation des
bus aujourd'hui de carolis est organisé
par prendre la santé syndicat mixte des
transports ne sommes un opérateur un
arrêt de quelques minutes à lens mi
temps l'occasion d'échanger sur les
besoins qui ont conduit à la création de
cette ligne
voilà la première goutte il faut
remonter jusqu'à 15 minutes
donc entre douze et quinze minutes on
s'est beaucoup plus avantageux de faire
une heure avec l'iphone 5 est
embouteillée d'options toiser les vous
avez trois arrêts alors toi il tout ça
c'est dans la dénégation services du
plaqueur c'est un système qui fonctionne
très bien
j'aurais vu aussi que le nombre de
voyageurs de touristes donc je pense
qu'il faudrait pas la suite compris chez
nous celle où mettre les moyens de
manière à ce qu'on puisse simple
fonctionner convenablement le modèle de
transport maritime martiniquais semble
avoir séduit l'autorité guadeloupéen en
martinique un billet unique de transport
maritime et terrestre est annoncée l'île
soeur devrait adopter le concept